nouveau numéro de reporter sur France 24
depuis le début du conflit en Ukraine
les musulmans sont nombreux à prendre
part à l'effort de guerre plusieurs
bataillons se sont formés sur le front
et la société civile s'organise pour les
soutenir si la plupart de ces hommes et
de ses femmes sont des Ukrainiens
d'autres sont originaires du Caucase et
parmi eux des Tchetchen le Parlement
ukrainien a reconnu en octobre dernier
d'ailleurs l'indépendance et
l'occupation par la Russie de la
République tchétchène d'ischkiri
ensemble ces musulmans ont choisi de
défendre les valeurs de l'Ukraine face à
leur ennemi commun la Russie raï Abu
saïdé bonjour grand reporter à France 24
vous êtes avec nous de retour du crâne
ce combat beaucoup d'entre eux le
considère comme un djihad alors même que
l'Ukraine est un pays majoritairement
chrétien
bien évidemment les Ukrainiens notamment
les musulmans considèrent ce combat à
cette guerre qu'on leur guerre contre
contre la Russie et tanjihad parce
qu'ils défendent leur terre défendent
leur famille ils sont même à appeler ou
utiliser le terme jihad parce que
l'Ukraine est un pays laïque et le
moufti nous a rencontré l'ancien Mounty
qui n'a pas d'autorité religieuse et
administrative et la dijonnais pas
utilisé le mot jazz mais je considère ce
que font les musulmans aujourd'hui en
Ukraine est en sorte de djihad pour
défendre le crâne leur pays leur famille
et leur terre alors on va découvrir ce
reportage que vous avez tourné
Ukraine les musulmans dans la guerre un
sujet d'Anaïs Guerra et ride Abou Zaïd
qu'on retrouve juste après
[Musique]
une ambulance de retour du front à son
bord un militaire une balle logée dans
l'abdomen
ça va c'est normal tiens bon on arrive
dans 10 minutes
la guerre a fait de saillie d'ismaelov
un aide-soignant volontaire
depuis le 1er décembre on fait des
évacuations tous les jours en ce moment
il y a des combats de rue donc nous
avons des soldats blessés par balles
nous ne sommes pas autorisés à aller
plus loin la position de l'hôpital doit
rester secrète
Saïd nous donne rendez-vous au prochain
arrêt la mosquée de constantinovca
[Applaudissements]
à 26 km du front le bruit des obus ne
s'arrête pas
vêtus de son treillis l'imam est ancien
Mousty continue à diriger la prière du
vendredi
[Musique]
en grande majorité chrétienne l'Ukraine
compte un demi million de musulmans il
représente 1% de la population et
beaucoup d'entre eux se sont mobilisés
depuis l'invasion russe
c'est le cas de Mohamed Ali à Cardiff
il y a eu une bataille ici le 27 février
dernier
lorsqu’un petit groupe de Russes s'est
introduit dans la ville
de sa ville natale part en fumée
nous avons tout vu de nos yeux
[Musique]
des corps qui se consume
de comparer cela à quoi que ce soit
d'autre
un déclic pour moi
il rejoint alors la communauté musulmane
engagée de quartier
il rencontre Hadj Mourad un homony
volontaire dans l'armée
sont en train de mourir
des jeunes vont à la guerre et nous
enterrons beaucoup d'entre eux sans même
pouvoir identifier les corps
nous pardonner cela
un engagement nouveau pour la communauté
musulmane habituée à se faire discrète
auparavant le système politique était
conforme à la propagande russe
les musulmans étaient considérés comme
des terroristes
aujourd'hui la société est devenue plus
mature elle nous accepte tel que nous
sommes et cela nous permet d'être plus
actif
au centre culturel islamique chacun
prend part à l'effort de guerre
après son travail Natalie à Mansour
s’appelle à la fabrication de bougies
pour les soldats dans les tranchées
c'est pour leur permettre de se chauffer
de préparer de la nourriture et d'avoir
un peu de confort
c'est une façon de leur dire qu'on ne
les oublie pas
[Musique]
nous voulons les aider car il s'agit de
notre problème à tous
cette recette de conserve remplie de
paraffine Natalia l'a appris sur Youtube
en ces jours sombres pouvoir contribuer
à sa manière lui apporte de l'espoir
comment je me sens
mon cœur est rempli de joie
je suis fière de pouvoir faire ne
serait-ce qu'une petite chose
[Musique]
sont chargés par Mohamed Ali et Hadj
Mourad les deux amis prennent la route
pour approvisionner les soldats sur le
front
destination barmouth
avec la guerre tout peut changer en
l'espace d'une seconde
c'est pourquoi on a toujours un plan
mais seul Dieu sait ce qui va se passer
nous approchons de la cité sous le feu
de l'offensive russe
pour rejoindre les positions
ukrainiennes il nous faut emprunter
cette piste en terre
mais alors que nous entrons dans la
ville
nous percutons un bloc de béton
[Musique]
nous sommes bloqués entre deux positions
d'artillerie
mais il faut évacuer les journalistes la
presse ne peut pas rester ici
par sécurité Hadj Mourad prend très vite
la décision d'embarquer avec les hommes
de ce bataillon tchétchène
nous pénétrons dans les entrailles de
cette ville en proie au combat de rue
est une ville fantôme
[Musique]
il est pas tombé très loin
réfugiés dans le sous-sol l'aumônier
Hadj Mourad prend des nouvelles du front
que les envahisseurs russes étaient
rapprochés de
barmuter qu'ils sont parvenus à les
repousser
le fait de résister nous comble de joie
est un soutien précieux pour ses soldats
[Musique]
vient nous voir régulièrement
il nous remonte le moral
nous sommes contents de le voir
ensemble on va gagner
[Musique]
commun la Russie Muslim cheberlo yevski
et le commandant du bataillon tchétchène
charmant sourd il combat dans le
don-basse depuis 2015
nous ont imposé cette guerre
et c'est pourquoi nous devons nous
battre et survivre par tous les moyens
possibles
la plupart du temps nous employons des
tactiques de guérilla car nous n'avons
pas assez d'équipements militaire pour
faire face des gars à égal
d'artillerie ou même de lance-roquette
au moment de partir Nourdine s'assure
qu'aucun sniper ne nous attend au
tournant
pour ce dernier le combat contre les
Russes a commencé sur sa terre natale il
avait 14 ans
je ne pardonnerai jamais ce que les rues
sont faits dans mon pays jamais je ne le
pardonnerai
contre ce régime
jusqu'à ce qu'il soit détruit
je crois qu'à présent l'Europe et le
monde entier ont compris qui sont les
terroristes
à plus de 700 km de là à Kiev Maga est
une autre figure de cette lutte après
avoir étudié en France ce tchétchène a
rejoint le bataillon Joe hard ou daef
spécialisé dans les renseignements il
témoignent un visage
cachée
qui ont été abandonnés
des prises de guerre qui permettent à
Maga et à son bataillon de soutenir
l'armée
à aller jusqu'au bout donc on va l'aider
on va être leur côté jusqu'au jusqu'à la
victoire
et
défendre les graines ensemble contre
terror rouge
les Tatars sont originaires de Crimée
convertis à l'islam au 14ème siècle il
représente aujourd'hui la plus grande
communauté musulmane d'Ukraine
eux aussi sont dans le viseur de Poutine
des territoires
occupés
car beaucoup de bibliothèques qui ont
été détruites
animalière et le directeur adjoint de
l'Institut culturel en Ukraine d'origine
tatar il tente de préserver l'identité
de son peuple
les rues sont essayés de nous acheter
mais presque tous les tata ont dit non
nous avons une seule mère patrie
l'Ukraine et notre terre et la Crimée
la Crimée et de l'offrir en cadeau aux
Russes
alors cette guerre deviendra celle de la
génération à venir
aujourd'hui Ali mais la communauté tatar
enterre l'un de leurs soldats
Siran kaderov est mort à barmut
de plus un musulman ukrainien de plus
est mort c'était un homme courageux qui
se battait pour sa terre d'origine la
Crimée
pour les combattants du bataillon crime
seule la victoire de l'Ukraine rendra sa
dignité au défunt
c'est très difficile d'exprimer tout ce
que je ressens pour la plupart d'entre
nous c'était un frère je ne connais même
pas de mots pour décrire à quel point
nous étions proches
[Musique]
c'est une perte très dure pour nous tous
et nous prendrons notre revanche
le prix de la guerre les larmes et le
sang versé
un nouveau carré musulman a été ouvert
dans ce cimetière chrétien
le corps du soldat est enfoui dans la
terre
pour laquelle il a donné sa vie
et on se retrouve en plateau avec Raïd
Abou zaïdé de retour du crâne on l'a vu
dans votre reportage donc des troupes
tchétchène combattent contre la Russie
quels sont leurs motivations oui en
effet il y a deux grands bataillons
tchétchène le premier et le bataillon de
cher Mansour que nous avons accompagné à
barmouth et le deuxième bataillon est le
bataillon de Gerardo daev qui dans les
abords de Kiev le premier est spécialisé
dans les guérillas et le deuxième il est
plutôt conventionnelle combat
conventionnel assez métrique première
motivation des tchétchen bien au-delà
qu'il considère qu'ils défendent les
valeurs de l'Ukraine et de l'Europe il
rendait une dette il paye une dette aux
Ukrainiens parce que les Ukrainiens ont
combattu pendant les deux guerres de
Tchétchénie avec eux donc elle est
connue le nom de Alexander mosaico
frerdam frères d'armes et qui ne
l'appelait le frère à chrétien parce
qu'elle était le seul à avoir
autorisé à être rappelé frère sans être
musulman première chose comme vous
l'avez on entre de sujets aussi les
Ukrainiens le Parlement le radar a voté
pour reconnaître la République des
tutorias comme indépendante et en
dernier il combattent ils considère
combattre pour les valeurs de l'Ukraine
le valeurs de l'Europe aussi alors
autrefois ce musulmane combattante les
Tatars qui ont aussi clairement choisi
l'Ukraine comme contre la Russie et
pourquoi pour quelle raison les Tatars
se considèrent comme un crayon nous
avons pu parler avec
Issa caillé le commandant d'un bataillon
le bataillon crime et nous avons aussi
parlé avec Tamer l'attacheva et à
d'autres et choisissent le crâne ils ont
une histoire très douloureuse avec la
Russie 1944 plus qu'un quart de millions
déporté 46% mort c'est dans leur statut
statistique des tata en 1960 il y a
plusieurs messages envoyés surtout et
font face les Tatars aujourd'hui en
écrivait depuis septembre à la
mobilisation forcée pour combattre dans
l'armée dans l'armée russe nous peut
rencontrer Tamer l'attacheva permanente
représentante permanente de président
zenichky pour la Crimée et je vous
propose des côtés son message quand on
voit au tatar de la Crimée on l'écoute
je voudrais dire si vous avez la
possibilité de rester en Crimée restez
en Crimée
si vous êtes en âge d'être mobilisé dans
l'armée russe malheureusement quittez la
Crimée
mais ne vous engagez pas dans l'armée
russe
ne combattez pas contre votre pays et ne
combattez pas contre votre peuple
merci beaucoup pour cet éclairage très
intéressant sur la guerre en
Ukraine c'est la fin de ce magazine
merci à vous de l'avoir suivi on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine pour un
nouveau numéro de reporter sur France 24
[Musique]